ce matin là pierre assiste à un entrée
dans café pas d'atelier en présentiel
pour se plier au contexte sanitaire la
rencontre se déroule en visioconférence
suivi directement depuis son domicile à
montigny le bretonneux un temps
chaleureux pour échanger s'informer et
créer du lien autour d'une thématique
exemple pour cette discussion la
préservation des relations de couple
c'est une occasion de débattre de sujets
qui finalement nous conservons puisque
avant d'être mal bon c'est plutôt
sympathique rencontre des gens qui ont
les mêmes problèmes que nous qui les ont
résolu de façon parfois différentes et
il ya peut-être des choses à reprendre
en 2009 les médecins diagnostiquent à
son épouse une maladie génétique
son état se dégrade rapidement et pierre
se retrouve alors désemparé pour
s'occuper d'elle
il a besoin d' aide via la mutuelle de
son épouse ligny matin et mise en
relation avec l'institut de promotion de
la santé de saint quentin en yvelines
l'accompagnement des personnes
handicapées malades etc
ça comporte de très nombreux aspects que
ce soit financier juridique aide au
ménage aide à la toilette etc
il n'y a pas un guichet unique quoi
c'est au hasard des rencontres pour
prévenir l'épuisement et épauler les
aidants l'institut de promotion de la
santé propose un programme
d'accompagnement dédié
en plus des entrées dans café des
groupes de paroles et de soutien sont
déployées tout comme des ateliers
thématiques avec pour objectif de se
détendre et de mettre en pratique des
conseils
enfin une nouveauté le passe temps libre
la possibilité de se faire relayer
gratuitement auprès de son procédé pour
un temps de répit en finançant des
heures d'auxiliaire de vie qui peut qui
peuvent remplacer les dents aux côtés de
la personne aidée
c'est un dispositif qui se met en route
depuis très peu de temps qui s'appuie
sur les compétences des services d'aidé
à domicile qui interviennent sur le
territoire au premier trimestre 2001
environ 200 et dans était accompagné par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines